hi there steve here i am with my wife
uh we're in uh
dallas near the airport killing time
before we get on our plane to fly down
to argentina
so we thought we'd come to this mall for
something to do the mall of course is
predictable the same kind of stores that
you'll find in every mall everywhere in
the world it's these so my wife's gone
off shopping and i'm sitting here
so what i'm doing
is uh i'm loading up trafalgar by benito
perez
a book in spanish which i can i have to
open the lessons first on my ipad so
that i can then
read them and listen to them
on the plane so this kind of warms up my
spanish before i hit
argentina although i have um
enough arabic so i can vary it a little
bit of
arabic farsi in spanish and of course
these are fairly long because it's an
audio book
so i also am reading my kindle
uh which i started reading on my way
down here sort of a break from my arabic
studies
and because i've been studying farsi so
i've got this very interesting book
on the history of persia
which i've been reading because it takes
a while for these long audio book
lessons to load
and of course the thing about language
learning is you learn things because you
get interested in the culture of the
country
and it seems that um
in the zoroastrian religion which at
some point became the religion
of persia and which was the first sort
of
revealed religion that preceded
and christianity and obviously and islam
but it says here the souls enter into
paradise
uh is it first of all everyone gets to
go to paradise everyone gets to go there
all human beings irrespective
of rank and gender will go to paradise
old person parties garden
if they are worthy
the deceased is met on the bridge of the
separator by three angels who weigh up
his or her worldly deeds on a scale
if the scale tips towards the good deeds
the person is sent to paradise
if bad deeds to hell
i think that's wonderful everyone gets
to go there no amount of praying
professing your religiosity
or other
statements of how
you know pious you are will do you any
good
the only thing that matters is when you
show up they'll weigh
what you did in your life
that's pretty democratic as far as i'm
concerned anyway so that's what i'm
doing and in uh
let's say seven hours we get on a plane
and we fly down to buenos aires i'm
looking forward bye for now
[Music]